Three, two, one, zero...
From the earliest days of Apollo when
NASA landed the first humans on the moon,
IBM has had the distinct honor of playing a key
role in NASA's space exploration efforts. Fast
forward 50 years to today when the International
Space Station is helping to lay the groundwork for
living and working in space, a baseline for future
nasa missions.Traveling at over 17,000 miles per
hour and orbiting the earth every 90 minutes,
the ISS offers a one-of-a-kind microgravity
environment where crew members perform
research that cannot be done anywhere else.
Critical research like DNA sequencing on the
ISS provides foundational knowledge that will
be essential as NASA seeks to venture further
into space than ever before. However, analyzing
this research often requires data to be downlinked
to earth and processed by personnel on the ground,
a procedure that can take several weeks and delay
results. That's where IBM comes in in partnership
with NASA, ISS National Lab, HPE, and Red Hat,
IBM created the edge computing and space solution
eliminating the need to move massive libraries of
DNA sequencing data by presenting containerized
analytical code locally right on the ISS where the
data originates. This solution has the potential
to cut analysis time by nearly 50 percent opening
the door for many new mission possibilities.
In addition, NASA researchers will use
this platform to more rapidly develop,
test, and push code to the ISS in a fraction
of the time by leveraging Red Hat code-ready
containers and connecting to IBM Cloud running
OpenShift on the ground. This groundbreaking
partnership will not only expedite NASA's ISS
research but will help to lay the foundation
for future exploration opportunities on ISS and
beyond. We can't wait to support what comes next.